(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Nearly 3000 people attended
the Tribe of Nova Festival
in Re'im, Israel on Saturday.
(upbeat music)
It would become one
of the deadliest sites of Hamas'
surprise attack on Israel.
Over 250 bodies have been recovered
from the festival grounds
and surrounding area.
Here's how the attack unfolded.
The festival took place just three miles
from the Gaza strip.
Attendees arrived by
car and bus on Friday.
Just before sunrise on Saturday
the all night rave is still in full swing.
(upbeat music)
At around 6:30 AM,
concert goers notice a barrage of rockets.
Soon after the music halts.
(cameraman speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] As the rockets continue,
festival organizers
tell attendees to leave.
Around 7:00 AM,
confusion turns to panic as
attackers reach the festival.
(cameraman speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Many attempt
to escape via dirt roads
that lead to a main road,
but it creates bottlenecks.
Drivers encounter gunfire
from multiple directions.
(cameraman speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Many like Debora Avraham
abandoned their vehicles to take cover.
One car makes it out and drives south.
But just before 7:40 AM
they encounter a group of Hamas fighters.
20 minutes later on the same road
more fighters are seen
closer to the festival,
assaulting civilians at a bomb shelter.
The Southern escape route is now blocked.
Around 8:30 AM security attempts
to hold off Hamas fighters
approaching the festival
from the north.
(cameraman speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] That escape
route is now blocked too.
Large groups make
desperate attempts to flee,
running across open fields.
(people shouting)
Others remain at the grounds,
(lady crying)
(gun firing)
hiding in dumpsters,
and seeking protection
from security personnel.
(gun firing)
(people shouting)
Just before 9:30 AM,
Hamas fighters can be seen hunting down
anyone remaining on the grounds.
Someone appearing to play dead moves.
A fighter notices and executes them.
Survivors The Journal spoke to
describe an hours long ordeal
of being hunted by Hamas militants.
Devora Avraham moves from
place to place to stay alive.
(gun firing)
(Devora panicking)
After many hours, she makes it to safety.
Those who didn't escape were
killed or taken hostage.
(people screaming and shouting)
Many were brought back to Gaza
and paraded through the streets.
(people celebrating)
In a video circulated by Hamas affiliates,
one captive can be seen wearing
what looks like the
blue festival wristband.
Many attendees remain unaccounted for.
Hamas has since pledged
to execute hostages
as retaliation for Israeli airstrikes.
(suspenseful music)